Một quyền tổng thống thế này là Bà Diao Cí Vào Đưu Ké đã công bố lạc điều trình như sự chính phủ và sắp nhập bộ hàng
nhằm cùng có quyền điều hàng cho bất cảnh chính trường khá là các chia giải sọc imi bác sự tổng thống đi của laz Maduro.
Cú thể bà rô Đưu Ké đã ki quy định sắp nhập bộ công nghiệp bộ thương mại và bộ nhiệm loy sạn cho nhiều biệt gà sạch là bộ trường
ông Alex Sá, thưa cận về của tổng thống Maduro, thôi giữ bộ trường công nghiệp để đảm nhiệm nghiệp bộ khác.
Một giá ông, Andy Bộ Coronaldo đều bộ nhiệm làm bộ trường giáo thông,
con ông Megan Perez, Pirae Laz, giữ chức bộ trường thống tình và trường thông.
Tại quý đình đưa ra một ngày xo khi giám đốc cơ quan tình bảo trường mình Mỹ John Raph clip,
gặp bà rô Đư Ké tại Khá Rô Cá s, chung trường thông được cho lần nhằm phát đi tình hiệu cảnh khiển hợp tác sông phương.
Chuy đó, tổng thống tổng thống đi đông đông trong đánh chăm là điện đam bà rô Đư Ké,
và đánh giá thích cơ tức bất đi của chính quyền lắm thời.
Không linh quan tới về điều dưới là bôi trường có phòng Vladimir Padrino,
người Mỹ bài thông một chùi gí lấy tưởng niệm hơn 1 mọi mình xí về điều dưới là thiệt mặt.
Bì chính xích tấn tông của Mỹ ngày 1 mặt thông một ông Padrino cho biết chính phụ đã tích khoảng 1 đối bán đặc biệt thích
chỉ đạo của quyền tổng thống Rô Đư Ké.
Để hỗ trợ an sĩnh sả hội và phát triển tình tế cho thân nhận cái lịch sĩ.